Intermountain Health the sponsors of
this segment are reminding the community
that colon cancer screenings can save
lives we talked to one of the doctors to
learn more
I'm Dr schmidabot hematologist and
medical oncologist with Intermountain
Health March being colon cancer
screening Awareness Month Intermountain
Physicians want public to know that
colon cancer is preventable treatable
and curable with early detection in
United States colon cancer is the third
most common cancer among men and women
and is responsible for second leading
cause of cancer-related deaths 150 000
new cases of colon cancer are diagnosed
each year and out of those 50 000 die
every year with delayed diagnosis it's
hard to cure the cancer as well what
screening does is that we can diagnose
cancers at early stage an early stage
cancer diagnosis means better chances of
cure so people ask what is the
appropriate age for colon cancer
screening and I want to tell you
something that 45 is new 50. and the
reason being is that we have realized
the concert colon cancer is being
diagnosed at earlier stage than it used
to be now we have seen increase in colon
cancer incident incidents among age 45
to 50 as well so National guidelines
recommend new screening age 45. and the
purpose of screening is to detect cancer
at early stage
colon cancer starts with a small polyp
that can be detected easily on
colonoscopy which is one of the
screening methods for colon cancer not
just that you can diagnose small polyps
you can remove those polyps during the
same procedure and a lot of those
polyps turn out to be pre-cancerous
that's how you diagnose cancer early and
you can cure potentially during the same
procedure and I want you to understand
colonoscopy is not the only screening
test for colon cancer there are certain
tests that can be done at home such as
stool occult blood test fit test or
stool DNA so the major risk factors for
colon cancer are number one age
like I mentioned before most colon
cancers are diagnosed above age 45
and then personal history any personal
history that makes you at high risk for
colon cancer such as previous history of
colon cancer or certain high-risk
conditions such as inflammatory bowel
disease
and then strong family history of
cancers not just colon cancer but
certain other types of cancers as well
because there could be some genetic
predisposition in the family that might
predispose you to have colon cancer as
well in your lifetime and then colon
cancers are more commonly seen more
commonly diagnosed in African-American
population probably because of lesser
number of screening tests done in
African-American population and then
certain lifestyle modifications can
reduce the risk of colon cancer such as
exercise
avoiding smoking avoiding processed meat
so staying active and avoiding certain
types of foods and improving your
lifestyle can really reduce the risk of
colon cancer so screening equals early
detection early detection equals better
chance of cure so call us at
Intermountain and ask us to orienture
for screening as soon as possible
thank you Intermountain Health for
sponsoring this segment learn more at
intermountainnv.org Las Vegas now we
will be right back